Tony Hinchcliffe miss here Tony I'm very
sorry the I thought that maybe when you
came in we wouldn't have to deal with
this anymore but Jim has been doing bad
Johnny Carson impressions sunshine
Carson's terrible jokes isn't like Sam
presents as I can just adapt to where I
am and by the way they're not jokes
sometimes it's just pointing out that
the traffic's bad right yeah it was
crazy
have you noticed that living here
sometimes the traffic's bad I've noticed
once in a great while that the the
traffic is a little bit busier than
other places oh wow okay so there is
some truth in it okay maybe I should
give your jokes a little more credit
than you absolutely should cuz I'm
[ __ ] hello how long we walk around
that parking lot yesterday for and we
realize we're just on the 405
you're in LA when you stretch the last
beat of the thing that's what really the
fourth hi
I just I'm trying to change my persona
yeah you are it well you want to be more
industry yeah yeah yeah yeah I get that
I get that sure do you think it's only
being out here that like if Jim starts
adapting some of that into his style the
people will take it more like oh this is
this is Jim Norton he's one of the one
of the jet setters have come yes I think
if you do that thing like the talk about
the traffic stop with the 405 especially
I think that'll I think you know you get
that big boost to your comedy career
people a lot of validation people start
to take you seriously I hope is four or
five is a really inside joke right it's
not just like the only road that
everybody knows in California it's not
true I did I've done that joke in
different [ __ ] variations like one
time us I got lost in the parking lot I
realized I was just on the tin oh it's
really good isn't it
is it you mention a local reference and
then you just drive it home by saying
here in LA yes it's very good yeah those
are the two worst freeways the 405 and
the ten I mean that they're pretty much
always I never get on either one of them
I've lived here for over ten years and I
never take those two cuz anytime I do
it's just stuck right and it's amazing
that people just love it they just keep
getting on them yeah it really is crazy
side roads any streets faster pretty
much the airport to anywhere unless you
do four o'clock in the morning that's
the only time you take a highway yeah
your shoes are great what are those I
probably couldn't wear them to my feet
are all [ __ ] up those look comfortable
these are they're actually a Kenneth
HUL I just found them in a small window
you're not wearing wrestling shoes not
not this one no I have like a writing
gig after this oh so you have to dress
like a person yeah I see and can't dress
like you know like a wrestler like a
comedian that's what Tony likes to like
casually like his favorite shoe to wear
is an like an amateur wrestling shoe Oh
God walking around looking like a
wrestler people must think it's just
another Tuesday afternoon Hollywood
Boulevard my weight class is the 405 a
little bit a little bit bigger than I
look by the way if you if you tuned in
to our Facebook page Facebook / Jim and
Sam show you won't be able to see Jim or
myself or Tony
but the Tefft am live oh good we try
very well yeah Travis is there and I
knew I was embracing the tough can live
too much
Travis Taft is our producer back in New
York and he's again he's become quite a
phenomenon and so the people just want
to see what Taft is up to what he's
testing yeah and while I was doing the
live read he waved to me as he was
bringing the music down and I when I
waved back as I was looking at the
Facebook camera what a [ __ ] dope yeah
we really communicated what a know
showbiz dope so you are you Holly you
like writing for the people I [ __ ]
hate it I don't I don't really don't do
it anymore this is like sort of a cool
special gig that it's sort of secret so
I can't really talk about it but it is
like it is roasty like we're making fun
of people which is sort of my favorite
thing that's really the only and the
only reason that I even took this
writing gig is because I'm also going to
be on it but in order to be on it I had
to help them produce it so it's one of
those things like final level like I'm
like beating the writing videogames yeah
we're finally getting all the way out of
it yeah to where like I can now
negotiate well if you want me to write
for it then I have to be on it too yeah
that's good and so this is one of those
cool gigs and yeah I'm really pumped
about that I've been writing helping
people for for a long time I helped out
with that Bradshaw Roast that you were
on oh right that was really funny but
they could have been a better rose to
the crowd was not amazing right right
they weren't it was like a weird
banquet it was more like it felt like we
were in ducting Terry Bradshaw no like a
hall-of-fame rather than just you know
making fun of how long his nutsack is
yeah it was very very bizarre it's weird
I think roasts like arm are designed for
comedy fans but you know from doing
either from writing on the Terry
Bradshaw roast or from doing all the
wrestling roasts and stuff that you've
done that when you get in front of an
audience that's not a comedy audience
yeah they'll turn on you they don't
understand they get I mean did yeah yeah
and you just hope that so it's a rock
and roll crowd and when it is there's
nothing better yeah but when it's tough
it's tough yeah i roasted Gene Simmons
on Family Jewels like 2007 was it a real
roast or the real rose oh no no it was
real it was at The Whisky A Go Go or one
of those places Wow and it was so great
and the crowd was on fire like they knew
what it was yeah they were [ __ ]
pumped and baby for TV gene took it all
that was great but sometimes these other
ones people like oh that's that's me and
why is he saying that my hero Fox's 10
year old daughter
handle it it was gene cool with that
gene Simmons he was I did one that he
was a role I forget what I mean I
something about [ __ ] seeing his head
slammed on a toilet after it was a
really mean joke but I did one of my
Paul Stanley being gay was a good joke
and gene went it's not true he all
getting you yeah but yeah all it all he
took it great every time I've seen him
since then he's been [ __ ] phenomenal
have you had to deal with people like
roast subjects or whatever that did not
like what I was just saying gene there
was that not you oh she was looking
right at Tony who's that wrestler that
stabbed the guy in the ring new jack oh
yeah new jack is that his name yes
well everybody Jake is like this this
like super thugged-out wrestler he's a
last guy who hasn't figured out
wrestling's fake right so like he uses
weapons and stuff but he's been multiple
times he's had assault charges filed
against him literally stuff he's done in
the ring because he stabs people he'll
cut him open way too deep like the whole
deal he literally shanked a guy once
during a wrestling match like real
stabbing cuz whatever and it was like
crazy the guy's just bleeding it anyway
everybody's like be careful I don't know
what New Jack sense of humor isn't sure
enough like we did the roast of the Iron
Sheik I think was in New York City I
think you're at Caroline's yeah yeah
and uh and New Jack was on it and man I
was laying into him and cheese he got up
and I was scared man cuz it's all a joke
until you're literally physically being
touched and like yeah by somebody that's
that strong and maybe they're kidding
maybe they're not I mean you don't even
know until your head snapped you know
what happened he just sended up like
really scaring me just like just
grabbing me and being like is this what
you wanted to do you're gonna keep
making the jokes I'm like actually I am
I got a couple more left I and they're
like I had yeah exactly like I just was
I just sort of didn't back down but at
the same time I did like physically I
was like no but mentally as opposed to
physically back down you enjoy how'd he
take it when you said I got more I think
he I think he sort of got it actually I
think had I been like no I won't do it
anymore then he would have been like
damn right like probably given me one
last shove but instead of I'm sort of
like yeah I'm like I got a job to do and
you're part of it new jack yeah yeah
isn't that the same Road where Virgil
like attacked Kurt Metzger yeah yeah
Virgil that was a sad one yeah Virgil
didn't like the jokes that Kurt Metzger
was making about him being lonely oh so
he went but I think and I think he hit
him they need her something physical you
didn't punch him in the face or anything
how do you at least shoved him it did
something it was a very that was an
awkward one that New York one had a lot
of like cayenne pepper to it like it was
just like thick and audience was angry
yeah that one's yeah I got invited to
that I couldn't do it for some reason
now I would I really wish I was able to
at the time yeah the audience got pissed
because they were all like wrestling
people so when the medians like Tony who
by the way Tony is like the biggest fan
ever yeah but they didn't know who he
was sure so he goes up or any of the
other or Metzker or any of the other
comedians go up and start making fun of
their heroes absolutely and [ __ ] on
them they all got pissed exactly all got
pissed and you just loud boos cuz it's a
real pro wrestling audience so you're
trying to eat they're treating you like
you're the bad guy and you try to own
into it and they just hate you more what
I mean right like I would try to heal up
I'd be like whatever New York City
you're just a bunch of idiots I'm gonna
go back to the 405 exactly where people
are really crazy which is just the
average weekday in LA
Hey and the weather by the way horrible
I get a really good smog joke today
this morning you did know you mentioned
smog this morning no wasn't a really
good joke [ __ ] kill by any stretch of
the imagination how long you been doing
it how long you been doing Europe August
uh three and a half years Kel Tony yeah
every Monday live at The Comedy Store
and you've done it consistently yeah
that's amazing in fact the longest break
we ever took was this past one right we
just came back yesterday that you guys
were on and I was two weeks it's the
longest Weavile I don't like doing
Australia oh you really okay yeah how
was Australia for you oh my god so great
it was right oh so cool so many cool
comedy fans and just great shows and
that like you talking about audiences
man did they get it and they are allowed
you know it's like Canada sort of but I
maybe even a little bit more like on
steroids Canadians and Australia I feel
like they just have this thing where
it's like bring it let's go take me away
you know talk about anything let's get
into it you know that I think they just
want to show you like it edgy and hard
and fun yeah yeah they want to show and
they want it hard so you know that makes
it fun because then you you feed that
feed off that energy lesson you need is
like you get up there and you just start
and they're going oh oh that happened to
me once actually in Sweden I didn't
realize I mean they were they were they
were liking it it turns out but I
thought I was bombing because they don't
verbally laugh that much they're more of
like clappers and it's very hard to
explain
mm-hmm I could have sworn I was bombing
but afterwards everybody's like you did
good what are you talking about
not on date they're not like hahahahaha
they're just like but they were loving
it but they did you know light laughter
right whereas like Australian Canada I
feel like America maybe even comes
behind them as far as like you know yeah
hard you want to go fall yeah why don't
you do it when you're down there could
you could another podcast was just a
hook of the technological the Technium
yeah technologically I got nothing and
read ban is a the producer guy okay he I
couldn't bring him so it was just all
stand up and what is this now and I what
is this thing between you and Ron
Bennington I wanted to ask you about
that is there anything or is it nothing
it's
now okay good it effective uh he was
brought up on Rogan and I literally
talked about it being nothing cuz Joe's
like what's up with this show and I'm
like oh it's nothing some people said
that it was the same I'm you know I mean
it's like you know they have a verges
somewhat of a version of that show but
how many what I want yeah yeah and but
you know it's just it's the only thing
that sort of annoys me is that it's an
interrobang thing or however they came
together with whatever and I know people
there that know me well that I know are
fans of kill Tony and it just sort of
bugs me that I guess you know if you if
you they liked my show I would have
loved to have had a chance to have been
on something as cool as Sirius XM and
instead they're just like let's start
this new show that's what do you think I
mean and I have to ask Sarah her raunchy
I was actually was to do it tonight
right here in LA cuz Ronnie mo he's
gonna be pissed you went did kill Tony
instead no I had only heard that to his
rumblings and I never heard you say
anything about it but Ronnie is a
brilliant guy and he's a completely I've
heard integrity and he's a he's a genius
and he's an absolute 100% integrity
there's never not an ounce of stealing
and Ron Bennett I really and I and I'm
not thinking that at all I think that if
anything you know the idea for a we
should get comedians and goofing on
comedians type of show continuous comedy
type of thing you know I think there is
always space to do something like that
every single one of my buddies in New
York big J and Ari and all my close pals
there have all immediately reported back
like hey Ron Bennington's cool you guys
are you know just to let you know like
he would never do this and it's like so
we're all totally cool it's just you
know people on the internet they hear it
come up for a second on a podcast like
Rogen's or like this one even you know
I'm sure it'll even this will even fire
up enough you know traction to get
something going on Twitter and then all
of a sudden there's people going you
know hey you're an idiot because Ron but
you know what I mean
it just happens quick it all gets out of
control I don't hear the answer like I
literally heard something and I didn't
know what the conclusion of it was right
now I'm like I don't think Tony would
bash right didn't make sense to me and
um so yeah that's why you but it's also
not dissimilar I mean we were talking
before we did the show about the kind of
incarnations that stuff like
has happened in the past car crash
comedy that Opie and Anthony did or the
the key room or whatever it was that you
talked about there are that seems
frightening yeah tell me tell us about
the the key room in Atlanta there's an
all urban show already you lost me where
the whole audience big crazy crowd takes
their keys out if they don't like you if
you start to lose them for a second they
start to take their keys out and lightly
jingle them humiliating so if you start
to really bad the whole place just has
their keys and it sounds like just a
vibrating uh it sounds like you're in
somebody's pocket have you done that oh
no I haven't no it's just part of like I
think we were talking about earthquake I
think that's part of his like legacy is
that he came from he was built in this
like dark room where keys are jingling
and and I don't know if you fail you
lose you know I mean and I don't know if
anybody can really put into context but
the reason that I found it like because
you got to think that one person is not
going to like a joke and all you need to
hear is because you'll hear the first
one and all you need to hear is one set
of keys jingling and all of a sudden you
get thrown off your game like a wedding
[ __ ] when they want to kiss the bride
right one starts and then the minute you
get thrown off your game somebody else
is gonna pick up on it and then it's
just like you're you're [ __ ] right
you're [ __ ] the story that I heard
it's like sometimes you'll just walk out
and people will already be jingling
their keys they don't like your shirt or
they don't like the way you're walking
or something like that and you're
already fighting without even saying a
word on it no it would be fun to do once
would you like that sure why not I mean
I've gone before I mean the worst it can
happen to say jingling keys and you
leave exactly do you like rooms where
you're battling the audience because the
comedy is so weird because you've seen
it we'd like a room like that you have
to go out you have to battle the
audience and winning is like you're
fighting them and you only win when they
start laughing with you right which is
crazy how will you do it likely what
I'll do is it the crowd is being loud
I'll be like folks they didn't pay me to
come up here and police the room and I
kind of quiet them down that's so
because I see the logic behind that yeah
yeah oh hush up that's cool I'd like to
do the quiche oh that sounds like fun
pet but do you like battling audiences
like that
I mean I always love it when I get to
you and I get to have something outside
you know
the playbook just call an audible and
have fun with anything just get
something different a minor heckle or
this or that I love slamming you know
just anything that throws throws me
something where I can improvise and sort
of show the crowd that it's a live show
you know I mean the worst is when
they're trying to help you like the guy
who's a yeah yeah like he's enjoying you
so you don't want to hit him too hard
cuz he's having fun but it's like oh
[ __ ] shut up yeah that's the worst I
don't have a guy hate my guts and heckle
because then he's throwing down the
gauntlet you could take the gloves off
and [ __ ] murder him yeah but it's
when they having fun with you that you
have to walk carefully and because then
the audience will walk away from you if
you totally mean to a guy who's having
fun with you yeah it's a weird line yeah
it is some guy in the middle of my set
last night said happy Halloween really
loud just a one quiet part where I was
like moving on or resetting from
something and you could tell that he was
just waiting for the one moment where he
could just get this in and I just
stopped everything and I'm like even
saying that to everybody tonight into a
whole thing just I really bashed him and
then I just felt like it wasn't coming
across because then he went completely
quiet after that and that sort of bug me
like I asked him a question like after
that like are you gonna you know like I
can't remember what the question was but
it was just something and he wasn't
answering and I go you know you're not
gonna talk now you're not gonna talk
just started laying into his girlfriend
for really no reason of pent-up anger
you wanted a heckle but now you don't
want to answer the one question that I
have legit question right good for you
I'm gonna make you pay right so I'm just
like a you know lady I can't imagine how
much your life must suck you know being
with this guy I mean really I mean I
would make a joke about it but I'm just
talking about how low quality of a human
being both you and him must be because
that's how he is in public I mean you
must be the scum of the earth if you're
in love with this guy I mean you're
hanging out you go out with this guy
fans out of all these strangers in this
room is a terrible person you know
because you know I yelling at you
dressed really weird I mean that sounds
crazy but that's typically just a
Saturday in LA
[ __ ] never gets all gadgets it gets
really old really because my book but
you know that like that because you did
that it's not gonna exist in the club
like they're gonna get in the car and
she's gonna go I don't know why you'd
let him talk to me like that I don't
know and it's just gonna inundate him oh
yeah you uh when I saw you headline
Caroline's it was a little while ago
yeah I think it was last November yeah
you had to you had to throw a couple out
oh yeah you end up but you a like
security wasn't coming you had to talk
them out of the room yeah I've done that
quite a few times it happens yeah and
and they got they got very offended that
the comedian on stage and look at your
shoes look at you like they would like
really fighting back the only time I
ever have to kick somebody out is when
they have blacked out drunk pretty much
that's the one that's my kryptonite it's
like you really can't beat sloppy sloppy
day drunk pretty much like even night
drunk I can handle like it's in my zone
but if the and I know I can you can tell
from a mile away if they've been day
drinking you hear it in your first few
minutes up there doesn't become a
problem until 20 minutes later but you
hear the rumblings you just frickin feel
hear it oh yeah that low murmur that you
like sometimes what I do and this will
at times work is I'll talk quieter or
I'll slow down like I did that in Philly
one night this is it was a crazy
Halloween weekend so they were all drunk
I'm crazy yeah but I mean it was like
you know amped up energy and the same
thing in LA Halloween there no nothing
like that
Oh totally different okay oh man I get
you that you're gonna mean something of
course too much integrity behind it and
I started talking very quietly and just
doing this for just a second because
then that sound gets isolated and then
you can hear him and you know who's
talking but then he would stop so that
sometimes that will shut them up if they
realize they're being loud yeah but
other times they just amp up and then
you know at least you know who the [ __ ]
is talking if that's an interesting
approach because I always do the
opposite I always try to go louder and
make them back down and but that's what
he wasn't talking to me he was just at
the table talking some of those things
going back and forth and when you do
that then they become self-conscious
because then you're also not burning
material because you're talking about
something kind of
Dain for a second it also helps I would
think because then all of a sudden the
audience is hearing them talk so then
when you do light them up it's like dude
where we all hear you you know they all
hear you yeah sometimes I'll say hey
keep it down to a dull roar yeah that's
fun because it's fun cuz it's like we're
all having a good time beep some keeps
them in line that's good where did you
develop your your your armor like ever
hurt I'm not talking to you like an
earthquake
you know keiki rooms and that's why I
like where where did you comedy store
between the hours of 12:30 a.m. and 2:30
a.m. help used to be open even later
than that like we have a Brian Holton by
the way he's still there yes great yeah
right so fun we always like me and Rogan
will make a point if he's there on a
Saturday main room like Saturday night
we'll go in after doing our spots and
everything and kicking it for a bit
we'll go and he's one of the only comics
that we watch ever did he go on last oh
yeah oh it's so funny it's so funny you
know the material is pretty much
probably what you've seen but it never
you know gets old I mean he's just
unbelievable he's got the most fun
delivery and just you know and it
changes that's a guy that in between the
jokes like really I'll just be in the
moment crazing you know when people are
walking out he just owns that last spot
he's really great at it I love how much
Rogan still enjoys comedy because I
could find that you were saying that he
does that because remember when we were
in Vegas we all went out to see dice
oh he's told me about this and I went
those guys yeah yeah cool and I mean he
was like he was laughing harder than
anybody in the room Rogan was me I had
the time of his life he loves it and
everything he does he loves
I mean Rogen is a super freakish human
being he really is I mean if you think
about his body of work like you know I
mean Fear Factor even is such a
hilarious show right look at what it is
that seems like a dream show for anybody
those plus you talked about coming back
Fear Factor that return that it made the
money that he probably made from it
getting paid to have people drinking
bull semen or whatever and he doesn't
have to do any of it
he needs just
what he does in the UFC which is
basically just being reactionary like
right [ __ ] like a superfan and
educated yeah yeah but he loves the UFC
sits in the front row of his favorite
sport throws on a headset no prep just
kills it you know what I mean like he
knows everything just from being a fan
of it right
same thing with comedy super fan of
comedy you know a fan of knocking out
deer with an arrow 400 yards away yeah
he's he's an amazing human and was my
point
oh he just does what he loves like and
that's what we that's a cool thing about
getting to work with him is and that's
what him and I do talk about we're not
talking I don't choke out you know bears
with my bare hands like he does that
were all the only pretty much thing that
we relate about is our love for stand-up
and talking about crazy stuff like
hecklers and shows and although when
you're around a guy like that you go
like okay this is because a lot of
people don't have that right they don't
have that type of a person in life so
they don't think to themselves I could
just do the things that I love to do
like I just spend my life doing the
things that I like oh yeah I mean he's
totally inspirational right it's
incredible you know he's the one that
told me to shoot my own special and just
knock it out and worry about it later
and I did and that was a huge
game-changer for me yeah and in just
everything I mean he's just superior
sort of and he's like a father and his
kids love him and it's sort of crazy
because when I come from I mean there's
just a bunch of you know losers around
me when I was a kid in Ohio and my dad
and I mean but just a ton of people
everybody's a loser
yeah of a sudden you see some guy that
can do everything and it's like wow
that's crazy
he's I should try to do stuff yeah yeah
do what you want you can knock it out
and just do what you want where people
tell you when you did the special cuz
we're talking about the special before
you came in and how it was all you know
done in one shot with no cuts like
Birdman mmm-hmm um did you how many show
me shows did you see how many shows how
many cameras with this one show one
camera I made it myself I hired a
Steadicam guy direct a director an audio
guy the club one show I had one shot at
it
and that was that there any moment you
wish you could have done better
oh yeah oh yeah pretty much the whole
thing yeah that it wasn't probably
wasn't even in my top 80 percentile of
sets that I had you know that year you
know what I mean
but it was also one of those things to
wear and I know this sounds cheesy but
artistically I sort of wanted it to be
different and I sort of wanted to give
the people like it sounds weird but like
a real experience that's different than
just kakakaka here's the way what I'm
getting is like anytime I sort of glance
upon a special or see one for a second
excited I don't really watch stand up on
a screen anymore ever because I get to
stumble in on a whole tomato Joey Diaz
or whatever you know and it's like I'm
sort of numb to it all but anyway I
always feel like the laughs are like too
long on specials when you're watching
it's a big theater if you're watching on
your couch by yourself you're not
laughing as hard as the people in the
theater right so I always just feel like
it should be tighter and whatever so I
helped that by not getting many laughs
on my special I mean like you know just
one of those things where I shot it in
the club and you know it's just sort of
raw and real and I loved of the Icehouse
okay in Pasadena oh just a freeway trip
oh my god what should we do you take
there well actually it's the one 110
north okay no joke about the one town or
something no yeah no it's a good point
it's a good point um why did you decide
to do one shot I'm sure about this but
well know again this was sort of just
like I've always been a fan of Scorsese
and Tarantino and those kinds of cool
that Goodfellas scene yeah walking into
the Copa totally and in the beginning
and end of my special I sort of pay
homage to that because I start outside
of the outside of the comedy club and
walks it and follows me in and goes
behind me and around and then when I
leave it follows me back out to the same
spot and oh that's all part of the one
shot yeah oh cool yeah so it starts
outside and then I end up where I
started and it ends how it started and
and it really is I mean it's one
continuous cut at the end of it like
when when
they said cut I literally go did you
guys get that was there any problem like
I mean you just don't know because I
really only did have one or if they're
like oh we didn't we didn't know we
forgot you wanted us to follow you
outside you're like right bugs get
anything a battery could have died
anything could have happened and there
were a couple points to where you know
the tilt or whatever I don't know
Steadicam technology or whatever the
tilt went off and they had to go in and
correct it like millisecond by
millisecond was the whole thing
afterwards and editing but yeah I mean
it was so amazing and you know it was
one of those things to where to get to
have it go to Netflix yeah it was insane
what do you do now like what would like
is that's such a big highlight like how
do you maintain that that buzz well just
by writing and keep performing and
getting ready for the next one you know
wow in people when they see me and
having my next material be better than
my old stuff yeah I mean it's just
trying to follow the momentum and just
keep having fun it feels so good to do a
new joke that works my dad thing it's
the greatest thing in the world maybe
not working a new business that's the
talk that Rogan and I have more than
anything is we talk about new bits
because it's literally like tough you
know it's like having a baby
it's like wow this came from something
inside of me and now it it does that to
people that reaction normally this comes
from something I'm wiping off my chest
or face do you do you date you have any
uh perversions uh do I date do I have
perverts are you in a relationship and I
just got out of one newly single for the
first time I willingly uh well I was in
this past relationship for like a year
and though but I went straight out of
one into another one and so I've been
based at this is my first time being
single in about four years Wow I meet or
no uh I don't know if I did in New York
we're at the deli and II might I don't
know there was just about okay our
relationship is Jeff yes yes Jeff was
with our relationship stuff for you just
because you have such an intensity about
like your work cuz I've gotten to know
you a little bit you just strike me
you're very intense about yeah I mean
you do
finding continuously and yeah that plays
that definitely plays a role in things
not going great with relationships right
definitely something that I've learned
is that you know if the relationships
good then it goes bad and if the
relationships bad and you're still in it
living my lifestyle going to you know
hustling from this to a writing gig to
an audition in the middle of that
writing producing gig and then right
after that audition I could go back to
the writing producing gig and then right
after that I have a friend coming in
town who's coming to see me tonight
where I'm performing at the store and
then I have to go to hang out at roast
battle right after that midnight and
then do it again tomorrow morning so
it's like there's literally no time this
is just a random Tuesday in LA you know
but but my point is like um you know
there's just nothing there's no chance
and not to mention you know I'm sort of
having cool stuff happen for the first
time ever going to Australia for two
weeks right just do it you know like I
did the Wilbur theater in Boston a few
weeks are just cooler bigger gigs than
I've ever imagined so it just sort of
takes me out of it a little bit and
relationships are tough in that scenario
because as you're like at first you're
like okay the relationship might have to
suffer a little because you have to
grind as much as you do to get to this
next spot but then once you get to that
next spot
there's only more and you try a lot of
girls yeah yeah all of a sudden you
realize like well I can [ __ ] all three
of them not just the one at home yeah
yeah faith I can get Netflix girls now
very hard not to [ __ ] at least
intrigue sexually you'd if you don't
cheat yeah you know it's it's hard not
to to take advantage of it as I like to
say the fruits of one's labor it's very
difficult to not especially for comics
who are usually low self-esteem morale
you didn't grow up with it right right
right so you start to indulge yeah
totally
I've always had you know smaller frame I
mean I mean I was always like sort of
cool for being funny in high school but
I was but that didn't really get me laid
you know what I mean you know it's like
boom all of a sudden just somebody
flipped a switch and it's just like you
know there's beautiful beautiful women
and sometimes they're not even beautiful
sometimes it's just something sexy about
1/2 luckily check you know yeah
absolutely just a big with a good
attitude
it's a workhorse that is that really is
yeah can he a Clydesdale plow horse I
mean type of girl you wouldn't like one
[ __ ] being a photo album with her but
she'll slide three fingers in your ass
and worship your feet that's [ __ ] a
great girl that is right sure
so you have is it is it easier to work
on the level that you're working on
right now being single it's got a right
oh yeah deficit yeah then you JD another
thing with me is that I'm not like even
though I'll you know all this stuff
happens it's not like I'm some soulless
[ __ ] like I would feel bad I would
feel bad for this poor girl that did
feel like she wanted to just all I want
to do is like hang out and get dinner or
go to a movie or something and it's like
Danny I god I can't believe I can't do
that I feel bad you know and then you
feel bad during the day and on your way
from one place to the next instead of
thinking of that next joke or something
silly or just anything to prepare for
your next thing right you're sort of
just like hey I hope everything's okay
and it's like you get a text back it's
not okay right it's like oh then you
feel bad you know and I know you resent
them and you start getting angry it's
like um this is a job what do you think
this is yeah right a hobby then just
everything spun out of Constanza cladded
with am i a bad person like I'm right
and you're like I don't time to be
wondering that which yeah and that's
something you don't want to be wondering
right before you go onstage or have to
go chop something right yeah you know I
don't deserve that people laugh at me
and have a good time all right he says
[ __ ] I can't even have the one person
who supposedly I love and loves me happy
right even make them haven't gonna make
a stranger happy with with the ones to
jingle their keys in ten seconds right
did you enter tushy it was super mutual
I was yes an angry one or kind of like a
pretty angry yeah yeah pretty long
brewing tough we were deeply deeply
deeply in love when we very first
started like it was like seemed like a
super perfect match and then all of a
sudden just boom train wreck what was
the first like little [ __ ] in the armor
[ __ ] in the armor I was I ruined it I
mean I messed up I went and
you know I cheated and and that was it
and she went through my phone found out
and that was it
those are two two things that once those
two things happen it's on have had the
phone one it's impossible you're
carrying around an undeniable record in
your hand yeah it's hard to delete that
stuff too because it's fun to go back
and jerk off to but it's like even like
on a psychological even though you know
you have now the guilt of I cheated on
you have so naive but what you thought
but you also end up with this severe
resentment like get the [ __ ] out of my
phone let me live my life get out of my
sleeping the crazy thing and I knew that
and again I know this sounds cheesy too
but when I did the cheating thing my
thought at the time my mentality truly
was I like this girl that's the new
girlfriend so much that since I just
gotta went straight from this was in the
very beginning of this relationship my
thought process was since I just got out
of a relationship and straight into this
one I'm gonna do this because I know I'm
gonna be with this girl for a long time
so I'm out of town this is my one chance
to do this better get out yeah right and
it was the opposite what dead because I
did that it ruined everything
what'd you find what did she find in the
phone was it a picture or was it a text
that was it was an eyeball yeah it was
just yeah I was enough I back enough
messages yeah okay now last night was
great type of thing no we all you did it
more than once I know it was one time
but she able to forgive you or no no it
never it never got better and then it
got worse because then yes the
resentment began and all this and all of
a sudden I did want to I got so mad that
I did you do start messaging other
people and this and that and then all of
a sudden boom she found that somehow and
like it was just on you know a normal
thing was just out of control because
she was just trying to figure out what
she could do or what it was what the
problem was I don't know it's hard to
explain but you're absolutely right
these devices it's a whole new thing
yeah I mean back in the day
you would have to imagine find an actual
love letter you'd have to intercept it
in a mail like what is this letter right
this girl sent you sir
sir boyfriend you know and I find the
old shoebox full of saving love letters
you know it's just everywhere
yeah there's ways to like crack it you
know what I mean like if your phone
rings and you're in another room or
whatever you don't have to have the
passcode right or something like that
somebody could just open it and then
it's open and then you have it am i
right like there's good open it probably
hang up the call real quick and then go
through the phone yeah exactly or or or
if you have the iCloud thing yep that
and you forget that your texts come up
on your computer that's crazy and iPad
all somebody's somebody's using your
computer yeah that's what actually did
it for me it wasn't actually the phone
it was an iPad connected to the phone in
the iCloud it wired it all at that
[ __ ] iCloud I would literally rather
[ __ ] just jot down my information
with a pencil like copy it from my phone
and use that [ __ ] iCloud yeah you got
delete stuff oh she saw it as a campaign
well I don't even do it anymore I won't
even connect to the iCloud anymore and
it sucks because my notes and now my
recordings all my sets and all my jokes
and everything I like the iCloud for
that but it's just not worth it to me to
have anything out there you learn
immediately like I mean and it's not
like I'm there's hooking up with all
these chicks it has nothing to do with
like you know protecting myself from
people knowing what I'm doing with girls
it's not about that it's just about
everything man it's so weird this thing
where yeah it's just crazy how many let
me ask you started Sam's married if you
open your phone how many text messages
down is it not who is it but how many
text messages down is on the top where
there's something that would be
embarrassing uh probably almost
immediately one of the first
conversation tell you I'm really curious
about for you open up your text messages
and if you go down the list what is the
would where do you get to a conversation
that you don't need everybody seen um
you know not as many as I would actually
more first ex-girlfriend as a friend of
mine second buddy of mine third girl
that I'm working on but we haven't said
anything embarrassing so there's nothing
in there I wouldn't want you to see
fourth is Bobby
which by the most humiliating a career
level ah v is my friend who we saw last
night so there's a couple of personal
things in there right but that was
somebody who is like a legitimate friend
so that's not like a real bad one will
you specifically had a clean night you
last night last night a female friend
and a director Wow oh boy yeah number
seven or eight what about you Tony my
older brother makes you know I couldn't
I mean I guess I'm gonna talk about it
on a radio but instead I mean you know
my older brother makes an n-word joke
like five messages down I like that
straight into the tech right edge right
and it's one thing to mention that it
happened on the radio there's plausible
deniability and stuff but I don't think
he needs that in in in text showing up
anywhere delete stuff like I hate to
delete tech leader no I can't guys don't
do it yeah it's weird so much easier
just to get rid of them yeah hmm I can't
do it then I don't delete text bees then
I don't it then if it starts back up
again you don't know where it left off
or anything like that you know what I
mean I buy it's a weird save thing
snapchat I follow like very few people
on snapchat because you can't save them
and but now I'm watching I'm like yeah I
don't need to save every interaction I
think that's why really young people
like snapchat is for them they've always
had stuff that was savable and
collectible and capturable you're also a
collector of things like the same way I
am yes
like I don't ever like to throw anything
I collect laughter I mean not to be too
Mike maudlin but I collect laughter yeah
well the collection is not going well
I'm just saying are you a collector of
things not really not really
I mean you mean just anything like stuff
yeah like Jim and I both are the type of
people that Havers a lot of stuff for we
hoard but not dirty [ __ ] like just
things I'm in general yet you know what
I do say that I can't get rid of and I
don't know what I'm gonna do with it is
everything I've ever written like no
matter what this show or anything so
that's great dax of papers of just
scribbled notes and you'll be going
through one thing you're like wow this
is from the Trump roast right oh my god
this is you know I guess that craziness
this is because we all think we're
DaVinci on some level right and I was
gonna find these notes someday and then
do something with them they're just
worthless garbage by saving though
packing slips fragile stickers from 1990
when I started and I worked at
Christophe silver and I would write down
jokes on the [ __ ] as I was packing
silverware yeah it's like you just say
save dollars yeah we should we should
break his carry Keegan's coming in but
Tony Hinchcliffe thanks for having us on
kill Tony really Auto students very very
enjoyable you guys were great that was
so much I hope you didn't mind that I
didn't talk that much but it's almost
like no one minds that but you're great
you had some great questions yeah
there's just there's so many funny
people yeah that that are all involved
in that in that from the band to the to
the to the dais or whatever you call it
and the comedian's a lot of them were
well some of them were really good I was
kind of bummed because with the episode
we taped last night
a bunch of the ones that I wanted to be
like that was not good they were likes
my first time on stage and I was like
actually actually really not bad for
your first time right for the first time
they were actually like really good well
they were nice yeah I mean yeah for me
it's hard to be really nasty to a
comedian who's nice if he's new like
right like the guy was a dick poor guy
that did the 60 second long holocaust
joke that was but he never said to set
up yeah all the matter nothing terrible
yeah we made fun of other stuff on he
was he was make fun of ogre in his
clothes he really did it like David
Berkowitz to have been shooting a couple
you can get a kill Tony on on iTunes
where else uh it's on there it's on
YouTube Vimeo uh catch it on Ustream
live streaming every Monday live from
the Comedy Store or Emmy at live there